at first sight the village of kodox
seems to be a pocket of peace and
tranquility in war-torn South Sudan the
River Nile is an important source of
livelihood and identity for the shelach
South Sudan's fourth largest tribe but
the Nile is also the frontline
government forces loyal to President
Salva Kiir are stationed on the eastern
side while troops loyal to exiled rebel
leader react mature control the western
river bank frequent exchange of fire
across the river makes daily life
difficult for the fishermen because of
this conflict we can't go to the main
river if the soldiers see you even if
you are a civilian they'll shoot you as
a result the fishermen have been forced
to retreat to a small tributary of the
Nile but there is little to catch here
most of the fish are in the main river
where the water is very shallow and
sometimes it disappears during the dry
season many she look fear that even
their limited access to the river could
soon be lost in an unprecedented
military campaign government forces
recently took over the previously
rebel-held town of Wow she look located
on the West Bank just an hour south of
here dozens of people were injured many
of whom were brought to this hospital
nobody knows how many were killed
officials blamed the rebels for
provoking the assault but this rebel
soldier says government forces attacked
first the campaign is seen as an attempt
to seize land that belongs to the
shelach I'm not fighting because of
politics I'm fighting because of the
land if somebody came to take your land
would you accept that you yeah would you
fight back while the men are staying
behind to fight women and children have
fled further inland and away from the
river that is their source of livelihood
there is really not much here in this
forest there is no shelter no food and
very little water but thousands of
people have decided to stay here anyway
because they feel it safe because at
least this place is a few hours away
from the frontlines
water is particularly scarce 20,000
people share three small water points
like this one for weeks
exhausted families with small children
have been sleeping on the trees
surrounded by the few belongings they
managed to salvage when fleeing their
homes the situation is exhausting I
don't know where part of my family is
some of them ran in other directions and
I'm alone here the conditions aren't
helping either there's no water
we were waiting to get water all day and
still we haven't managed and there's no
food okay the vertical Murphy this fish
is the first meal of the day for this
family but it doesn't amount to much
when split between 12 people famine has
already been declared in other parts of
South Sudan but a catastrophe could
unfold here as well Aid has started
trickling in and can at least ease the
hunger most people have lost hope that
the international community can do any
more than that the world doesn't want to
see the South Sudan problem nobody can
solve our problem and especially the
problem of the shelach the Shalaka
finished driven from their land and away
from the river the shilla are facing an
existential crisis with nowhere else to
go returning to Sudan the country's
South Sudan seceded from almost six
years ago is the only option left